[تصفيق
] أتذكر
الاحتفال مع الجميع ،
وأتذكر أن الجميع كانوا سعداء
للغاية ومتحمسين للغاية مثل وجود بلدنا المستقل
الخاص بنا ،
لقد كان من المذهل
أننا شعرنا بالحرية
[موسيقى
] استيقظت في الصباح في الواقع
مثل يوم عادي.  استيقظت من
نومي ، كنت أرتدي ملابسي كنت أنتظر سيارة مكتبتي لتأتي وتقلني
قليلًا لدرجة أنني أعلم أن كل ذلك كان
صراعًا كاملاً حدث في الليلة
السابقة لأتذكر خروجي من منزلهم
بعد سماع الكثير من الضوضاء
والناس الذين يبكون الناس يصرخون
القدوم إلى حيث كان الطريق الرئيسي
، وهذا هو المكان
الذي أدركت فيه أنه لا بأس من وجود حرب في
عام 2013 ، بدأت الحرب
بالضبط في الخامس عشر من
ديسمبر في مساء يوم الأحد ، عندما
بدأنا في سماع هذه
الطلقات النارية ،
أتذكر تلقي مكالمة من بلدي
أمي
كانت تبكي لذا لم أكن أعرف ما كان
يحدث
، ثم في الخلفية كل ما يمكنني
سماعه
هو أصوات تم تشغيلها وانهارت
لأنني كنت أعرف أن هذه كانت نهاية الحياة.
عائلتي
عندما اندلع الصراع كان هناك
نزوح كامل
معظم الناس نزح الآلاف
ثم اضطروا إلى البحث عن
ملاذ من دول التحنيط
التي تركت العديد منهم يعانون
من الجوع ، وهناك
صعوبات يواجهها اللاجئون
هناك.  قلة مرافق الرعاية
الصحية ، ثم كانوا
يفتقرون إلى المياه والاحتياجات الأساسية
عندما لا يكون أطفالنا هنا معنا
بسبب الحرب إذا توقف الماء
وجاء السلام من هذه
السنوات العشر القادمة
ربما أطفالنا  يمكن أن تأتي إلى هنا
وتبقى معنا معًا ،
أملي في المستقبل للسنوات العشر
القادمة هو
مجتمع متحول
حيث
يمكننا أن نعيش تعايشًا متساويًا فيما
بيننا
حيث أرى شخصًا ما هو أخي
ويرون شخصًا ما أختي
ومجتمعًا حيث  نحن
نشجع المشاركة حيث
يمكنني فقط التحرك دون أي قيود
حيث يمكنني التعبير عن مشاعري
[موسيقى
] لأي شخص بغض النظر عن العرق
بغض النظر  من القبيلة وهذا هو
المجتمع الذي
أه أتوق إليه هو الجيل الشاب
الذي سيلهم الجيل الذي
سيأتي
بعدنا مع جنوب السودان ، لدينا
الكثير لنفعله بشأن هذا
الأمر متروك لنا لاختيار الحياة التي نريدها
عش ، دعنا نفكر في هذا مثل إلى
متى سنكون
في هذه الأزمة التي تعرفها إلى متى
نتوقع أن نرى
حياتنا داخل الكوابيس ، لذلك دعونا نفعل
شيئًا إنه
يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً حقًا ولا ينبغي أن
يكون على النحو الذي
نحتاجه  سلام نستحق أن نكون في سلام